[Applause]
splashing down off the florida coast the
trailblazing capsule carrying the first
all-civilian crew to ever orbit the
earth inspiration four on behalf of
spacex welcome home to planet earth
thanks so much
the voice of the mission's commander
billionaire jared isaacson he paid an
undisclosed sum said to be about 200
million dollars for the flight and his
three guests blasting off from cape
canaveral on wednesday
the spacecraft built and launched by
entrepreneur elon musk's company spacex
was fully autonomous and operated by
teams on the ground whole journey uphill
was only about 12 minutes so before we
knew it we were hanging in our straps
and floating uh and then we were like
what do we do next
the capsule soon reached an altitude of
about 585 kilometers above earth the
farthest any human has flown from our
planet since 1972. this is the largest
window ever flown in space
we can put our head in and fit multiple
crew members and see the entire
perimeter of the earth and the views i
have to say are out of this world
elon musk has reportedly said he's more
interested in building the
infrastructure for private space travel
than taking off himself
this space odyssey was far higher faster
and longer than the recent flights by
musk's space rivals and fellow
billionaires richard branson and jeff
bezos
theirs didn't orbit the earth and lasted
mere minutes but together the three
outings have launched a new era in space
tourism i think it brings excitement and
it actually gets more people interested
in space
and not only that but this particular
flight
was part of a fundraising effort for st
jude children's research hospitals so
it's it's done a lot of good
its return involved a plunge through
earth's atmosphere that sent
temperatures outside the capsule soaring
to 1900 degrees celsius
that's such a cool shot of dragon
coming back down to earth
it then parachuted down into the
atlantic shortly before sunset with its
jovial crew exiting the craft less than
an hour
later what's being called the second
space age is now underway
alexi o'brien al jazeera